one of President Trump's personal
attorneys Rudy Giuliani is notably
absent from the legal team defending him
in the Senate CBS News senior
investigative correspondent that's
Catherine Herridge spoke with the former
New York City Mayor yesterday and
Catherine good morning to you seems like
he had a lot to say well he did and good
morning and it's great to be here with
you thank you very much in a
wide-ranging interview Giuliani said
he's ready to testify in the Senate
impeachment trial if he gets clearance
from the White House and he directly
challenged John Bolton's motivation and
version of events here's the only
conclusion I can come to and it's a
harsh one and I feel very bad about it
he's a backstabber Rudy Giuliani
unloaded on the president's former
national security adviser John Bolton
whom Democrats want to testify in the
Senate and Pietschmann trial - John
Bolton tell you to shut down your
investigation into Ukraine he never tell
you how much worse it isn't Giuliani
says on the president's behalf he
investigated corruption allegations
which included the former vice president
and his son hunter who sat on the board
of a Ukrainian energy company but so far
there is no evidence of criminal
wrongdoing by either Biden if the former
national security adviser had issues
with his work Giuliani told CBS news
bulletins did not complain to him he
never said to me I've got a problem
with what you are doing in Ukraine never
once never winked never sent me a little
note that's classic backstabber so I
feel I got a swamped character here I
find his testimony about the president
pretty close to incredible but during
congressional testimony a former White
House aide said Bolton did complain to
colleagues over Giuliani's work as well
as efforts to force out the then US
ambassador to Ukraine Fiona Hill
testified Bolton compared Giuliani to
was a hand grenade that was going to
blow everyone up he came up to me and
said Rudy here a grenade that'll blow up
in each other's face I would say I would
never have the opportunity cuz you're on
atomic bomb if the Senate calls
witnesses should john bolton testify
john bolton should not testify if the
president feels that it is executive
privilege material Giuliani said he
first found out about the hold from the
media in any of your conversations with
President Trump
that he tied the military aide to
Ukraine's investigation of the Biden's
never ever discussed military aid with
the president with regard to Ukraine the
White House legal team called Giuliani a
quote minor player and shiny object
designed to distract the former New York
City Mayor said he maintains contact
with his client are you still the
president's personal attorney yes I am
when was the last time you spoke to him
two days ago if you're still his
personal attorney should you be part of
the White House defense team well I am
but I can't participate in what goes on
in the Congress because I'm a possible
witness on Twitter the lawyer for
Giuliani's former business associate
loved Parnas said his client can't
attend the Senate trial because of his
GPS ankle monitor but he will be in
Washington today to support quote a fair
trial with witnesses and evidence
partners worked with Giuliani on Ukraine
and his under indictment for campaign
finance fraud there's a lot of context
we can add I think one thing we could
say is that john bolton may not have
approached rudy giuliani because Rudy
Giuliani was outside the White House
that was in yeah and and john bolton may
feel that I mean you could he could say
that
Rudy gently Giuliani effectively
backstabbed him in terms of policy
because there was a conflict there and
if we get the testimony from bulletins
he can answer all of those questions be
interesting a friend of mine called me
yesterday and said rich to hear Giuliani
called somebody a bit backstabber
considering he told his wife he was
getting a divorce at a news conference
when she had no idea that was coming
some could say that's a backstabbing
move he's colorful I'm glad you're part
of our team really nice to have you here